on va faire une interview briseur de
ménage alors là on y est sophie est ce
que vous êtes toujours amoureuse de
pierre oui vous dit sur un ton banon
mais celle ci apparaît surprenant
présent mais je crois que ça se
construit de plus en plus je veux pas
qu'il a un peu vieilli mais c'est pas
mal ça lui donne un charme
supplémentaire
j'aime bien les porter j'aime les
charmes charmed et bwin
les pantalons en cuir à son âge je
trouvais ça j'aime moyen moi un mail me
trouve très sexy en 17 ans qui mena fait
acheter
facv total look en cuir c est ce qui
vous regarde toujours avec la même
fougue
non tu es ça dépend des jours ça à des
jeunes non mais ça dépend des périodes
il ya des périodes où il est plus ou
moins amoureux ces courses qui vous a
dit je t'aime pour la dernière fois en
début de semaine mais ce qui s'est fait
un post it chaque début de set vous
croyez que c'est pour vous qui reste
aussi coq est aussi ouais ouais c'est un
peu suspect quand même ça non non pour
moi puis c'est son boulot qu'on va me
fais moi-même de la télé qui n'a intérêt
à faire attention
en tout cas ce que j'ai constaté c'est
qu'il met guéri surtout lorsqu'il à une
émission de télé a présenté puisque pour
me le dire - c'est ça ça compte plus
quand même vous êtes d'accord avec sa
pierre visiblement oui oui oui oui il va
gueuler dans la bagnole rentrons la
dernière fois que vous amenez un
week-end en amoureux c'est quand ça
existait déjà
je sais pas où on est c'est vrai qu'on
n'a jamais trop l'habitude de partir
tout le donnez moi non plus des
week-ends avec vos enfants
on a couru ensemble et
et à chaque fois on annule un les
week-ends en amoureux je sais pas
pourquoi
bientôt bon il vous ouvre la portière de
voiture oui
ouais ils vous donnent la main dans la
rue oui il vous faut encore le petit
déjeuner au lit
oui enfin au lit non mais il me
préparant un petit déj tous les matins
quand même l'islam tous les matins moi
je me lève tôt à 6h30
il se lève avec vous à cette adresse
une grossesse qui fait de la télé tout
non c'est pas ça c'est quand elle a
commencé son émission il ya sept ans je
suis dit pour t'aider je me levais
rituel matin vers le petit déjeuner je
savais pas de cette durée de sept ans
série en cours
ils vous regardent la télévision où ils
regardent le foot comme tout le monde
un tu me regardes page séparée je relève
le compteur de temps en temps ils
regardent les filles dans la rue alors
il est très faux culs allez dire que
c'est le mec qui voit pas très bien et
il n'a jamais vu le super canon qui veut
ça donc c'est toujours moi qui n'y ont
pas vu la fillette est là
mais je me rends compte qu'en fait il y
voit très très bien et est en fait c'est
nanti fonctionne j avais jamais pensé à
quitter n'ont pas sérieusement quoi vous
a traversé l'esprit mais n'en n'ont
jamais vraiment pour la saint valentin
il fait quoi en général il est il est
assez attentif quand même globalement
c'est quand c'est tout ouais ouais ouais
vous engueuler ah oui
ah oui ah oui dieu après après ça en
général
non mais enfin gagnera ou on s'en va et
on est on est pas très souvent d'accord
en fait un don il faudrait arriver à se
convaincre qu'ils ont maintenant cessé
choix professionnel moi je suis pas
toujours d'accord avec ses choix et on
discute dur et quand je le gonflage et
il m'est arrivé de me prendre un pot de
peinture jaune indélébile à l'huile sur
la tronche quand même ouais ouais ouais
tu que je te gère mais robin fait
plonger des ratés général et taper une
belle couleur
une escale et ses chaussettes
ah ouais ouais c'est ça que les graves
et durables pour descendre la poubelle
non pas trop ça sportif la manchette et
locaux les fringues par tout ça c'est
vraiment pénible
ouais moi j'adore lors d'un speed ça
fait combien de temps que tu n'as pas
arracher votre soutien gorge
récusant exactement c'est la fin de la
question alors t'es déjà tellement je
crois qu'il est pas très bon il est pas
très doué pour des graphes et 17 la mort
des records sur france 3 ça dépend
positif
il pense que les préliminaires c'est
important avec sa femme en toc ouais
ouais ils portent vos sous vêtements des
fois ils auraient du mal
ça c'est une question bon mais vous
n'êtes pas obligé de répondre si vous
répondez pas pierre répondre à toute
façon c'est quand la dernière fois vous
avez fait l'amour en dehors d'un lit en
dordogne
en dehors d'un lit pierre tu répondes
pas hier non je vous ai déjà proposé un
plan à quatre avec les castaldi flamand
barny oignon 1 point à 4 mains non 1,3
trop pourquoi
non j'ai pas de drame on a déjà parlé
ouais à succion si ce n'est ces sujets
sympa voilà exactement échanges
voilà c'est un pont exactement bien sûr
vous êtes jalouses de ses maîtresses
tant que je sais pas non mais il faut
rester vigilant fragile en temps vous ya
pensé à faire la grève du sexe pour te
faire chier
voilà d'où l'utilité des maîtresses et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu